BEAUTIFICATION SERVICES. I
DISCUSSIONS LIKE TODAY'S
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIND BALANCE AND
REGULATIONS THAT PROMOTE
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND PUBLIC
SAFETY WHILE ENSURING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. THE BEAUTIFICATION
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. IS A AS
AS AS A CASE STUDY PROVIDES A
NUMBER OF AVENUES FOR EXPLORING
HOW WE MIGHT UPDATE OUR SYSTEM
MY GOAL IS TO DO A TOP TO
BOTTOM REVIEW OF THE BOARD AND
THE PRACTICE ACT I WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO QUESTIONS TO MOLD
ASSUMPTIONS WE MIGHT HAVE AND
TO LOOK AT A SENSIBLE
REASONABLE REGULATORY SYSTEM.
LIKE TO WELCOME MY COLLEAGUE
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE EVAN LOW HERE TO MAKE
ANY OPENING REMARKS WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENSIBLE
LIKE TO ECHO THE SAME TYPE OF A
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO
WHAT WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE FROM
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PARTNERSHIP WITH RESPECT TO
SOME OF THE REFORMS AND BEST
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
AND ANOTHER TO THEM FOR
QUESTIONS INCLUDING THAT OF
WITHIN A SPECIFIC ISSUES OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION ARE. A
HUMAN TRAFFICKING MANY OTHER
ISSUES OF IMPLEMENTATION BUT
LOOK FOR TO THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE CHAIR LOW AND- IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE TALK
ABOUT HOW MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTERFACE WITH GOVERNMENT. AND
YOU KNOW IN THE HEALTHCARE
FIELD NOT EVERYBODY HAS A BACK
PROBLEM AND GOES TO SEE A
CHIROPRACTOR. BUT NOT TOO MANY
PEOPLE DON'T GET A HAIR CUT.
AND SO IT IS AN IMPORTANT
INTERACTIONS THAT WE HAVE WITH
US. WITH OUR LICENSE PROGRAM
AND THEN THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE. I WANT TO SEE BEFORE WE
INVITE UP OUR FIRST PANEL TO
SEE ANY OTHER COLLEAGUES IN THE
KEY ON THAT. ON THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING
OTHERWISE WE WILL BEGIN. I
THINK THAT'S THE HIGH SIGN TO
BE AND SO. LET ME WELCOME. TO
THE OUR JOINT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS LEADERSHIP OF THE BOARD
OF BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY LEASES
ON THE BOARD PRESIDENT COME ON
UP DOCTOR KERRY WILLIAMS PRIOR
BOARD PRESIDENT AT A CURRENT
BOARD MEMBER. AND CHRISTY UNDER
WITH THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER. TO
ALL OF YOU WELCOME TO. THE
LEGISLATURE IN OUR ON OUR
OVERSIGHT HEARING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR OPENING.
SUMMARY WHAT YOU DO AND HOW ARE
THINGS GOING HERE. IN YOUR AREA.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS A
BACKGROUND PAPER THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED I ASSUME IT'S THE BILL
OF ON THE INTERNET. AND IT
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE FOR HERE IN
OUR HEARING ROOM SO THANK YOU
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
FORMALLY. HI GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE WELCOME AND
FOR HAVING US WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
ABOUT THE INDUSTRY. THOSE AT IN
ORDER TO GET STARTED I'LL GO
AHEAD AND GIVE AN INTRODUCTION
OF MYSELF. AS WELL AS- MY
COLLEAGUE HERE WITH ME MY NAME
IS LISA TONGUE IN THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD
APARTMENT COSMETOLOGY. AND WITH
ME TODAY'S THEIR IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT DR CARRIE WILLIAMS ON
MY RIGHT. AS WELL AS OUR
EXECUTIVE FIRST STANDARD. WE
JUST WANNA THANK YOU AND THE
STAFF OF BOTH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES. FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY. AND TO
TALK ABOUT OUR BOARD WHICH WAS
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
CHARGED WITH THE MISSION. TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. BY
PROMOTING ETHICAL STANDARDS AND
BY ENFORCING. THE LAWS OF THE
BAR BRING IN PP INDUSTRY. THE
BOARD PLAYS AN IMPORTANT. ROLE
IN PROTECTING CONSUMERS TO
INDUSTRY. AND THAT IS THE
PLANS. WE EVALUATE ALL MATTERS
BEFORE THE BOARD INCLUDING
LICENSING ENFORCEMENT AND
REGULATION. WE VALUE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AS A STARTING POINT
FOR FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS. SO BEFORE I GET INTO
THE DETAILS OF THE PORT ITSELF
I WANTED TO HELP YOU BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE COMPOSITION OF
THE BOARD ITSELF. THE BOARD IS
COMPRISED OF NINE. POINTED
MEMBERS FIVE OF WHOM ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR MORE
INDUSTRY MEMBERS WHO ARE
LICENSEES THE BOARD SAID DR
KERRY IS AN INDUSTRY MEMBER AND
I AM A PUBLIC MEMBER. DR CARRIE
IS A LICENSED BARBER AS WELL AS
A LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST AND
SALON OWNER AS WELL AS A DOCTOR
CHECK COLLEGE G. WHICH IS THE
STUDY OF HAIR AND SCALP
DISORDERS. SHE IS CONSIDERED BY
THE INDUSTRY AS AN EXPERT AND
SPECIALIST IN NATURAL HAIR
STYLING AND HAS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE FOR HER COMMUNITY IN
THIS RESPECT. AND AS A NOTE
NATURAL HAIR STYLING IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT UNDER THE PURVIEW
OF OUR BOARD. AS FOR MY OWN
BACKGROUND I AM IN IN LANGUAGE
MARKETING AND COMMUNICATIONS
PROFESSIONAL WHO HAS WORKED FOR
THE PAST DECADE ON ISSUES
RELEVANT TO THE ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. INCLUDING
ADVOCACY ISSUES OF
REPRESENTATION AND
DISENFRANCHISEMENT. I'VE SERVED
ON THE BOARD FOR THREE YEARS
NOW AND IN THAT TIME OUR BOARD
HAS GONE THROUGH MANY EFFORTS
TO MOVE FORWARD ON A NUMBER OF
ITEMS DETAILS IN THE PORTS
SENSE THAT REPORT WHICH WAS
SUBMITTED IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. JUST ABOUT EIGHT
MONTHS AGO. RIGHTS IN BRIEF
HIGHLIGHTS IN THAT REPORT IN
WHICH WE NOTED SEVERAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. OUR BOARD HAS
A VERY DIVERSE INDUSTRY AND AS
SUCH WE HAVE MADE LANGUAGE
ACCESS A PRIORITY. WE PROVIDE
ALL OTHER PUBLICATIONS IN
ENGLISH VIETNAMESE SPANISH AND
KOREAN. AND WE HAVE RECENTLY
TRANSLATED ALL HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS INTO ARABIC
FARSI AND CHINESE WE ALSO
PROVIDE REGULAR LANGUAGE ACCESS
TRAINING TO ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES. THE BOARD HAS A
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW COMMITTEE
THAT HEARS APPEALS OF CITATIONS
IN AN INFORMAL ENVIRONMENT.
PRESIDED OVER BY MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD WE PROVIDE FREE OF CHARGE
TRANSLATORS TO COLLINS. THIS
COMMITTEES WORKLOAD HAS OFTEN
CONSISTED OF AN EXTENSIVE
BACKLOG REQUIRING LICENSEES TO
WAIT SEVERAL MONTHS FOR
HEARING. THAT IS NO LONGER THE
CASE. THIS COMMITTEE NOW
OPERATES WITH NO BACKLOG AND
HAS. HAS EVEN REDUCED THE
NUMBER OF HEARINGS THAT ARE
HELD ANNUALLY AND WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE THAT TREND. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THE WORK
AND BETTER HEALTH AND SAFETY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THIS
COMMITTEE THAT IS REQUIRED BY
STATUTE HAS TOGETHER A DIVERSE
GOUP OF INDIVIDUALS. STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES. AB THE
INDUSTRY ADVOCATES LICENSEES
SCIENTISTS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. THE COMMITTEE
HAS DEVELOPED PERSONS OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY COURSE TO
INCLUDE. BASIC LABOR LAWS AND
PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL ABUSE
AWARENESS. THE COMMITTEE IS NOW
TAKING ON AN IN DEPTH REVIEW OF
THE PORTS HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS. I WILL BE MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE FULL
BOARD ON EXTENSIVE REFORM FOR
THESE REGULATIONS TO ENSURE
CONSUMER PROTECTION. WHICH
ULTIMATELY IS ALSO A PROTECTION.
OF OUR LICENSEES HEALTH AND
SAFETY AS WELL. THE COMMITTEE
ALSO TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE IN
DISCUSSIONS IT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WITHIN THE STREET
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THE
DYNAMICS DECISION HELPING SHED
CLARIFIED CLARIFICATION. ON
THIS ISSUE FOR A LARGE LICENSEE
POPULATION THAT UTILIZE
INDEPENDENT THAT UTILIZED
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
RELATIONSHIP. OUR BOARD
ACTUALLY JUST VOTED A FEW WEEKS
AGO AT OUR BOARD MEETING TO
SUPPORT AB FIVE WITH AN
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE ALL
EXEMPTIONS RELATED TO OUR
LICENSEES. AND REQUESTING MORE
TIME TO ASSESS THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND ISSUE SPECIFIC TO
OUR LICENSE POPULATION IN ORDER
TO BEST DETERMINE HOW TO
PROTECT TO LICENSEES FOR MISS
CLASSIFICATION. BUT STILL ALLOW
INDEPENDENCE AND INNOVATION
FROM OUR LICENSEES TO WORK
UNDER THE MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE
THE FEEL WORKS BEST FOR THEM SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON. LASTLY
INNER SUNSET REVIEW REPORT WE
MADE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE HOPE WILL BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN OUR FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED
STRENGTHENING THE BOARDS
OVERSIGHT OVER SCHOOLS TO
REDUCE THE SELLING OF OURS.
CREATE A STANDALONE HAIRSTYLIST
LICENSE AND CONSIDER THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN INTERN
PROGRAM WHERE STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN SCHOOL CAN WORK IN AN
ESTABLISHMENT AND BE PAID WHILE
THEY CONTINUE TO LEARN THE
IMPORTANT HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS. TALK TO KAREN I
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE GREATER
CONTACTS FOR THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL SOME
BACKGROUND INFORMATION FOR ALL
OF YOU TO BETTER UNDERSTAND OUR
INDUSTRY. THE REGULATION OF THE
BDM BARBERING INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
IN PLACE FOR OVER NINETY YEARS
ORIGINALLY IT AS TWO SEPARATE
BOARDS AND AS A COMBINED BOARD
FOR THE LAST TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS. WE ISSUE INDIVIDUAL
LICENSES TO COSMETOLOGIST
BARBERS MANICURIST ELECTROLYSIS
AND ASK THE TITIAN'S AND WE
LICENSE ALL ESTABLISHMENTS
WHERE THOSE SERVICES ARE
PERFORMED. WE ALSO HAVE JOINT
OVERSIGHT OF IMPROVE SCHOOLS
WITH THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY AS WELL AS JOINT
OVERSIGHT OF APPRENTICE
PROGRAMS. WITH THE DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS. SOME
STATISTICS TO NOTE FOR THE
BOARD WE HAVE OVER SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND LICENSEES. ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS WE RECEIVE AN
AVERAGE OF TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
NEW APPLICATIONS FROM
INDIVIDUALS. WE ADMINISTER
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
EXAMINATIONS AVAILABLE IN FOUR
LANGUAGES INCLUDING SOME EXAMS
IN PRESENTS TO BETTER
FACILITATE RE ENTRY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE LEAVING INCARCERATION.
WE ISSUE TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
LICENSES. AND RECEIVE FORTY TWO
HUNDRED CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. WE
ALSO CONDUCTED ELEVEN THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS AND ISSUE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
CITATIONS. IN ORDER TO BECOME
LICENSED AN INDIVIDUAL MUST
MEET THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
FOR THE PARTICULAR LICENSE TYPE.
EACH APPLICANT MUST COMPLETE AN
APPROVED COURSE IN EITHER AN
APPROVED SCHOOL WHICH CAN BE
PRIVATE OR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OR COMPLETE AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. THE BARBARIAN
COSMETOLOGY COURSES ARE THE
LENGTHIEST ACOSTA MYTHOLOGIST
MUST COMPLETE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS AND A BARBER MUST
COMPLETE FIFTEEN HUNDRED HOURS.
THE CURRICULUM FOR THESE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS INCLUDES
TECHNICAL INSTRUCTION AND
PRACTICAL OPERATIONS IN OTHER
WORDS THERE'S CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION AS WELL AS HANDS ON
OPERATIONS OR ACTUAL SERVICES
THAT MUST BE COMPLETED. ALL
COURSES HAVE A VARIETY OF AREAS
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO BE COVERED
IN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM FOR
EXAMPLE THE COSMETOLOGY COURSE
COVERS HAIRSTYLING PERMANENT
WAVING AND CHEMICAL
STRAIGHTENING. HAIR COLORING
AND BLEACHING HAIR CUTTING
HEALTH AND SAFETY DISINFECTION
AND SANITATION LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. ANATOMY AND
PHYSIOLOGY FACIALS INCLUDING
CHEMICAL OFFICIALS EYEBROWS
BEAUTIFICATION AND MAKE UP
INCLUDING WAXING MANICURES AND
PEDICURES. THIS IS ALL NDER
THE COSMETOLOGY COURSE. A
NOTABLE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
BERMAN COSMETOLOGY IS AT THE
BARBER COURSE FOCUSES IN AREA
ON SHAVING AND TRIMMING THE
BEARD WEARS COSMETOLOGY
ENCOMPASSES NOT ONLY HAIR. BUT
ALSO SCAN SERVICES AND NOW
SERVICES. THE STUDENT WILL
COMPLETE A COSMETOLOGY
BARBERING COURSE IN
APPROXIMATELY TEN MONTHS I'VE
ENROLLED FULL TIME. THE BOARD
CURRENTLY HAS TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE APPROVE SCHOOLS INCLUDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT OFFER
THESE PROGRAMS THE BOARD
APPROVES THE SCHOOLS BASED ON A
REVIEW OF THEIR CURRICULUM
EQUIPMENT AND SPACE AND TEXT
BOOKS WELL THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY APPROVE
SCHOOLS BASED ON A REVIEW A
FULL EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
WHICH INCLUDES MANY STOOGE
PROTECTION ASPECTS THE COST OF
AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM RANGES
DRASTICALLY FROM TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED UP TO NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WE RECENTLY CONDUCTED
A REVIEW OF THE TUITION COSTS
OF CALIFORNIA PRIVATE SCHOOLS
AND HAVE FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE
IS APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PASS THE
TITIAN ONLY TRILOGY MANY
CURRENT COURSES ARE MUCH
SHORTER. AND THEIR SCOPE IS
MORE SPECIALIZED TO THE
SPECIFIC SERVICES THAT WILL BE
PERFORMED. IMPORTANT NOTE
HOWEVER IS THAT THE ONE AREA IN
WHICH WE SEE BY FAR THE HIGHEST
CONSUMER HARM COMPLAINTS IS THE
ONE WITH THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
REQUIRED SCHOOLING HOURS BEFORE
LICENSURE. THE FOUR HUNDRED OUR
MONITORING PROGRAM. ONCE AN
APPLICANT COMPLETES THEIR
COURSE THE APPLY TO TAKE THE
LICENSING EXAMINATION. THE
BOARD MAINTAINS TO EXAMINATION
COMPREHENSIVE SITES THAT
PROVIDE BOTH THE WRITTEN AND
PRACTICAL PORTIONS OF THE EXAM.
AND AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN
COMPUTER BASED TESTING
LCATIONS. WE ADMINISTRATOR
SAM'S MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY THE
BOARD DOES UTILIZE THE NATIONAL
EXAMINATION THAT CONSISTS OF
TWO PARTS THE PRACTICAL HANDS
ON PORTION AS WELL AS THE
COMPUTER BASED WRITTEN PORTION.
SUCCESSFUL CANDIDATES ARE
PROVIDED A LICENSE IMMEDIATELY
UPON PASSING THE EXAM. AND AT
THIS POINT I'M ACTUALLY GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO DOCTOR KERRY
WILLIAMS TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW. OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AS MENTIONED MY NAME IS DOCTOR
KERRY WILLIAMS I AM THE
PREVIOUS PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD I AM A LICENSED BARBER A
LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST AND A
DOCTOR OF PSYCHOLOGY. ANY
CONSUMERS ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
POTENTIAL HARM FROM VARIOUS
SERVICES THAT ARE WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE THAT ARE
LICENSED BY OUR BOARD. WE WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
TYPES OF CONSUMER HARM WI FI.
AND HOPE THAT IT MAY HELP
FEES.
COSMETOLOGY BARBERING. IN A
REVIEW OF THE LAST FIVE YEARS
THE CONSUMER HARM CASES
PEDICURE INFECTION REMAINS A
CONSTANT AT THE TOP CONSUMER
HARM COMPLAINT. HOWEVER IT HAS
DECREASED IN NUMBERS OVER THE
PAST RECENT THREE YEARS. SOME
OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THE
OUTBREAK PEDICURE INFECTIONS
THAT THE STATE INDOOR IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSAND. FOOT BASIN
FOR NOT BEING CLEANED AND IF
COST A BACTERIAL OUTBREAK
LEADING MANY PEOPLE WITH
PERMANENT SCARS. THE BOARD MAY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO ITS
REGULATION AND WE DO BELIEVE WE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THE
MEAN FUTURE OUTBREAKS. HOW FOR
THIS SERVICE. A TOP CONCERN
FOR. SAFETY THE BOARD HAD A
CASE JEFF THIS YEAR WHEN
INDIVIDUAL PASSED AWAY AS A
RESULT OF CALM PATIENTS
ASSOCIATE A BACK. DOOR HOWEVER
WAS NOT THE RESULT OF AN CLEAN
BASIN. BUT A PRODUCT THAT FIVE
TWENTY IT WAS TOLD THAT BECAUSE
THEY BURN. THEN BECAME INFECTED
WHICH LEAD TO AMPUTATION. AND
THE EVENTUAL DEMISE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL. DO ARE COORDINATED
CONSUMER AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS
PARTICULARLY DURING SANDAL
SEASON CONSUMERS ARE BECOMING
MORE AWARE OF THE POTENTIAL
DANGERS OF. PEDICURES PERFORMED
IMPROPERLY. HOWEVER WE ARE
SEEING MORE AND MORE HARM IN
MANY OTHER AREAS. OVER
PROCESSED HAIR IS QUICKLY
BECOMING A TOP CONSUMER
COMPLAINT. WHILE WE MIGHT NOT
SEE A DEATH FROM A BAD CHEMICAL
HERE SERVICE WE DO SEE
CONSUMERS THAT HAVE SPENT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
ONLY TO EXPERIENCE EXCESSIVE
BREAKAGE HAIR LOSS SCALP BURNS
OR HAVE THEIR HERE TURN IN AN
INTENDED COLOR. WITH THE
INCREASING POPULARITY OF BARBER
SHOPS AND THE POPULARITY OF MEN
WEARING BEARDS THEY'RE ALSO
COMES AN INCREASED RISK. TO AN
INCREASED RISK OF HARM TO MAIL
CONSUMERS WE ARE SEEING CASES
OF RINGWORM AND FROM DIRTY
BARBER TOOLS. BARBER H. WHICH
IS A FUNGAL INFECTION OF FACIAL
SKIN COSTS FROM BEARD SERVICES
USING DIRTY OR CONTAMINATED
TOOLS. FAXING SERVICES REMAIN
ANOTHER TOP CONSUMER THREAT WE
OFTEN SEE FACIAL BURNS
RESULTING FROM THE IMPROPER
APPLICATION OF WAX THAT WAS TOO
HOT FOR THE SKIN. SKIN CARE
SERVICES ARE CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING WITH THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND CONSUMER
DEMANDS AND WE ARE FINDING MANY
INSTITUTIONS ARE PERFORMING
SERVICES THAT BELONG IN A
MEDICAL OFFICE AND NOT A BEAUTY
SALON. SOME ALL TOO OFTEN
EXAMPLES OF CITED VIOLATIONS
INCLUDE NEEDLES FOR BOTOX
INJECTIONS COOL SCULPTING TO
ELIMINATE FAT AND CELLULITE.
AND VARIOUS FILLERS USED TO
PLANT THE LIPS. OR DECREASE
WRINKLES. IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
RECEIVED BY THE BOARD HAS
INCREASED BY 22% WITH FACIAL
BURNS DOUBLING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. OUR BOARD
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM RELIES
HEAVILY ON OUR CITATION AND
FIND PROGRAM WE HAVE INSPECTORS
THAT ARE IN THE FIELD DALY
INSPECTING FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS IN THE FIFTY
THOUSAND PLUS LICENSED
ESTABLISHMENTS. IN FISCAL YEAR
200-018-2000 NINETEEN WE
CONDUCTED OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS AND ISSUED OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND CITATIONS FOR
VIOLATIONS OF OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS. IN
ADDRESSING THE CONSUMER HARM IN
THIS INDUSTRY WE HAVE INCREASED
OUR PRESENCE IN SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT THROUGH THE I MEAN
WE HAVE INCREASED OUR PRESENCE
IN SCHOOLS TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR HEALTH
AND SAFETY CORPS THAT IS NOW A
REQUIRED PART OF THE
CURRICULUM. TO ENSURE THAT
FUTURE LICENSE FEES ARE MORE
EQUIPPED WITH THE EDUCATION
THEY NEED TO KEEP CONSUMER
FAITH. I'LL NOW TURN IT BACK TO
MS KAHN TO DISCUSS THIS FURTHER.
AS NOTED PREVIOUSLY IN THE PORT
HAS JOINED OVERSIGHT OVER THE
PRIVILEGE SCHOOLS ALONG WITH A
PAIR OF PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY.
MOST SCHOOLS HAVE WHAT IS
REFERRED TO AS A CLINIC FLOOR.
WHERE CONSUMER CAN GO IN AND
RECEIVE SERVICES FROM A STUDENT
THAT IS COMPLETING THEIR CURSE
OF INSTRUCTION. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DURING SCHOOL
INSPECTIONS WE FOUND THAT
SIGNIFICANT FRAUD WAS TAKING
PLACE. WE FOUND MANY SCHOOLS
THAT WERE SELLING HOURS TO
STUDENTS ONLY TEACHING THEM TO
PASS THE TEST. AS WELL AS NOT
TEACHING THE BOARD'S RULES AND
REGULATIONS. WE REACHED OUT TO
THE B. P. P. AND STARTED
CONDUCTING JOINT INSPECTIONS.
TO DATE WE HAVE CONDUCTED
THIRTY SEVEN JOINT INSPECTIONS
AND AS A RESULT OF OUR JOINT
EFFORTS. THREE EMERGENCY
DECISIONS WERE ISSUED FROM THE
BPP AND THE SCHOOLS ULTIMATELY
CLOSE DOWN. WE PREVENTED MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
FROM FRAUDULENTLY RECEIVING
LICENSES THAT WE BELIEVE MAKE.
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
PROTECTING CONSUMERS FROM
POTENTIAL HARM BECAUSE THE
STUDENTS WERE TAUGHT ONLY
MEMORIZE THE EXAMINATION. AND
NOT TO FOLLOW ANY OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS WHICH WE
WOULD THEN SEE THE RESULTS OF
IN TERMS OF CITATIONS. FOR
LICENSEES IN VIOLATION OF OUR
BOARD REGULATIONS. THE SCHOOLS
WERE ESSENTIALLY DIPLOMA MILLS.
SELLING HOURS TO STUDENTS WHO
WEREN'T EVEN ATTACKING SCHOOL.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS IMPACT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF CONSUMERS
BUT ALSO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE LICENSEES THEMSELVES
SINCE THEY ARE NOT TAUGHT HOW
TO PROPERLY PROTECT THEMSELVES.
FROM CHEMICAL PRODUCTS USED
SINCE ONE ENVIRONMENTS OR TO
PROPERLY DISINFECT TOOLS THAT
COULD CAUSE THEMSELVES AS WELL
AS CONSUMERS HARM. WELL WE FEEL
THIS IS A STEP FORWARD AND
PROTECTING STUDENTS WHO ARE
CHOOSING THIS INDUSTRY
PROFESSION FOR THEIR ECONOMIC
LIVELIHOOD. AS WELL AS
CONSUMERS FROM HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISK WE DO BELIEVE THERE
ARE OTHER FRAUDULENTLY
OPERATING SCHOOLS REMAINING.
AFTER THE EMERGENCY DECISIONS
ULTIMATELY SHUT DOWN THOSE
THREE BAD SCHOOLS AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHT SCHOOLS VOLUNTARILY
CLOSER DOORS NEVER TO BE HEARD
OF AGAIN. NOT ONLY ARE STUDENTS
FROM BAD SCHOOLS NOT BEING
PROVIDED VALUABLE HEALTH AND
SAFETY EDUCATION THERE ARE ALSO
MISSING OUT ON INFORMATION
REGARDING BASIC LABOR LAWS ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS. ANTI
RETALIATION LAWS AND WAGE RATES
ALL OF WHICH IS REQUIRED TO BE
PRE ARE PROVIDED TO STUDENTS AS
PART OF THE BOARDS HEALTH AND
SAFETY COURSE. THE BOARD IS
AWARE OF THE DISCUSSIONS ON
DEREGULATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND THE QUESTION OF WHAT
SERVICES SHOULD REQUIRE
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE AND STATE
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. OUR BOARD
IS VERY OPEN TO THESE
DISCUSSIONS IN THE HOPES THAT
EVERYONE INVOLVED WILL BE
THOUGHTFUL AND DILIGENT AND THE
BOARDS MISSION TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS. OUR BOARD IS READY
AND WILLING TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH ALL
OF YOU AS POLICYMAKERS. AND TO
DISCUSS REFORMS. THAT COULD SET
THE STANDARD FOR MANY OTHER
STATES TO FOLLOW. OUR UNIQUE
VANTAGE POINT OF BEING FOR.
HARLEY I CONSUMER PROTECTION
COULD HELP ELIMINATE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR US REVISED WITH WHAT WE
HOPE IS HELPFUL INFORMATION AND
MOVING FORWARD IN THE SENSE
THAT REVIEW PROCESS. GOOD THANK
YOU MISSED ON AND DOCTOR
WILLIAMS FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WAS VERY INFORMATIVE AND WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH AND-
I'M TO CLEAR PUSH OF THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE ON LANGUAGE ACCESS.
AND AS YOU WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES MAKING SURE THAT THAT
EDUCATION IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
STUDENTS. WOULD EXPECT TO GET.
SO YOUR YOUR WORK IN THAT AREA
IS VERY MUCH APPRECIATED I HAVE
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS BUT I
WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO MAY HAVE TIME
SCHEDULES. THAT ARE DIFFERENT
THAN MINE AND MIGHT HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
DEFER TO THEM IF THEY WANT TO.
ASK ANYTHING AT THE AT THE
HEAD. YEP CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU FOR APPEARING BEFORE
US TODAY REALLY APPRECIATED. I
HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF HOW IN
DEPTH. YOU GO INTO SECURING A
PROTECTING. NOT ONLY YOUR
INDUSTRY BUT THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. CONGRATULATIONS AND I
AM VERY VERY IMPRESSED. WITH
THE FACT THAT. YOU HAVE GONE
INTO SO MANY SCHOOLS. AND
LOOKED IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS. AND EVEN TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU'VE CLOSE SOME
DOWN THE POLICING THAT YOU'RE
DOING. IS FANTASTIC. MY
QUESTION IS. WHEN A SMALL SHOP.
WHERE THE B. BEAUTY SHOP
BARBERSHOP WHATEVER HAS AN
ISSUE. THAT MISS WILLIAMS THAT
DISCUSSED. WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
YOUR INSURANCE THAT THE THERE
THAT THE GROUP ALL ADDS THAT
THERE'S A FINE THAT. THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND COULD GO TO
WHERE WHERE DOES THAT COME TO
COMPENSATION WHEN SOMETHING
DOES GO WRONG IT IS THEIR
ERRORS AND OMISSIONS INSURANCE
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IN YOUR
INDUSTRY WHEN. SOMETHING LIKE
THIS HAPPENS TO PROTECT AND
GIVE RESTITUTION TO THE
CONSUMER. WELL THE FIRST OPTION
THAT THE MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HAVE A FILE A COMPLAINT WITH
THE BOARD AND THEN WE HAVE
INSPECTORS THAT REVIEW THE
COMPLAINT AND IN OUR CITATION
DEPARTMENT IN SACRAMENTO. THEY
REACH OUT TO THE INDIVIDUAL AS
WELL AS TO THE LICENSE FEE AND
THEN WE BEGIN THE INVESTIGATION
FROM THERE. AND DO WE HAVE.
WHAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
LIABILITY INSURANCE SO YES AT
THE SALON OWNER I DO HAVE
LIABILITY INSURANCE SO THAT IF
SOMETHING WAS FILED AGAINST
MYSELF OR ONE OF MY EMPLOYEES
AND THAT INDIVIDUAL IS
PROTECTED.AND I BELIEVE THAT
MOST LICENSE EVEN THE FATE OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY WHEN
WORKING IN ESTABLISHMENT. THERE
SHOULD BE LIABILITY INSURANCE
THAT COVERS THAT LOCATION AS
WELL AS INDIVIDUALS WORKING IN
THAT LOCATION. SO I WOULD
IMAGINE BE VERY IMPORTANT. TO
NOT ONLY CHECK THE STATUS OF
THE LICENSE THEIR HISTORY. BUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
INSURANCE IN ITS CURRENT AND UP
TO DATE IN THE EVENT SOMETHING
COULD HAPPEN. YES I DO KNOW
THAT. I'M NOT SURE OF THE BOARD
DO WE WOULD REQUIRE IT WE DON'T
REQUIRE THE LIABILITY INSURANCE
I'M SPEAKING FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND HAVING MY SALON
WHERE I LEAVE MY FAITH IS A
REQUIREMENT OF MY LEASE AND I'M
SURE THAT MOST BUSINESSES
REQUIRE THAT. PARTICULAR
INSURANCE FOR THAT BUSINESS.
MISTER CHAIR I THINK I'VE I MAY
HAVE STUMBLED ON SOMETHING
BECAUSE OF WE HAVE ONE SALON OR
ONE. PROFESSIONAL WHO MAY HAVE
ERRORS AND OMISSIONS INSURANCE
LIABILITY INSURANCE WHERE THE
NEXT YEAR MAY NOT OR THE NEXT
SHOP MAY NOT. THE GENERAL
PUBLIC NEEDS TO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE GOD FORBID SOMETHING
COULD HAPPEN. AND WHO DO WE
TURN TO. THAT'S THE ISSUE YOU
HAD MENTIONED THAT SOMEONE
PASSED AWAY. YOU HAD MENTIONED
THAT THE FACT THAT THE
EQUIPMENT MAY NOT BIG. PLANS
PROPERLY AND WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE. BUT THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE ACROSS THE BOARD
THAT EVERY CONSUMERS EQUALLY
PROTECTED. SO I THINK I'D HAVE
TO LOOK INTO THAT AND SEE HOW
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO. HAVE IN
YOUR INDUSTRY A FLAT BLANKET.
OF LIABILITY INSURANCE THAT IS
EITHER PAID THROUGH A FUND. OR
SOME WAY THAT EVERY SHOP IN
EVERY CONSUMER. IS PROTECTED.
CENTERS LETTER WE AT TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS TO HEART AND THAT MY
STAFF AND- BOARD WILL EXAMINE
THAT IN MORE DETAIL AND THAT
WE- HAVE FUTURE. HEARINGS ON
THE ISSUE HELP TO REPORT BACK
TO YOU ON THAT THANK YOU. AT
CHIRLA TANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER AND AGAIN THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF PARTICULAR FOR THE
OF BOARD MEMBERS FOR YOUR
SERVICE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IT
IS A LABOR OF LOVE AND ZERO
HERE VOLUNTEER SERVICES VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED TO THE STATE I
JUST QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
ON DEMAND SERVICES HE WAS
ALLUDED TO OTHER DYNAMICS
DECISION THE CHALLENGES OF THE
CURRENT WORK FORCE IN THE
FUTURE OF THAT OF THE WORK
FORCE. CAN TO SORT OF ADDRESS
SOME OF THE WORK THAT YOU MIGHT
BE DOING TO BEST UNDERSTAND AND
I'LL WORK WITH THAT OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE DYNAMICS
DECISION AND THAT. OF CONSUMER.
WITH A. ON DEMAND SERVICES IN
THE TECH COMPANIES IN WHICH YOU
CAN. GET AROUND THAT OF THE
BRICK AND MORTAR BUT THEN. GO
DIRECTLY TO HOME THERE ARE
NUMBER OF COMPANIES INCLUDED
WITH THAT TECHNOLOGY
APPLICATIONS. RIGHT TELL
ACTUALLY IN THE PAST YEAR AND A
HALF THAT'S BEEN A HUGE PART OF
THE WORK THAT THE BOARD HAS
DONE. RELATED TO PERSONAL
SERVICE PAYMENT. AND WE DID
HAVE QUITE A FEW. PUBLIC
HEARINGS ALONG THE PROCESS TO.
BEST UNDERSTAND HOW TO PUT
TOGETHER A PERMIT TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO BE WORKING. FOR THESE
ON DEMAND SERVICES ON IN THEIR
HOME AND SO WE'RE ACTUALLY.
MOVING AT PACKAGE THROUGH
REGULATION. RIGHT NOW. SPECIFIC
TO THE PERSONAL SERVICE PERMIT.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE TIME LINE
FOR THAT WILL BE BUT IT IS.
LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
DRAFTED AND SUBMITTED. AND THEN
THE SPECIFICALLY TO THAT OF THE
DYNAMICS DECISION AS WEALTH AND
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO PASS A
COMPANY TO UNDERSTAND. OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT EXISTS WITH
THAT AND THEN ARTICULATED THAT
TO THE MOVING COMPONENTS AND
HOW THAT WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT.
WITHIN THAT OF THE LICENSEES.
WE HAVE. HAD SEVERAL MEETINGS
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED THE
DYNAMICS DECISION AND- ALSO
ATTENDED SOME TRADE SHOWS WHERE
THERE'S BEEN ACTUALLY SPECIFIC
WORKSHOPS HELD. TO ADDRESS THAT
AND WE'VE BEEN. TAKING A LOT
FILLED IN A LOT OF CALLS AND
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS M. IT'S
DEFINITELY KIND OF OUT OF OUR
PURVIEW TO GIVE TOO MANY
DETAILS TO OUR LICENSEES SO
WE'RE KIND OF WAITING FOR
THINGS AS THEY COME OUT WE
POSTED ON OUR OUR AND SOCIAL
MEDIA BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
REACH MOST OF OUR- M. LICENSEES
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO AT LEAST
pSPECIALLY WHEN AB FIVE CAME OUT
WE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS ON
THAT AS AT OUR BOARD MEETINGS
AS WELL AND HAVE INSURED ARE
ALL OF OUR FACEBOOK FOLLOWERS
ON INSTAGRAM FOLLOWERS THAT IS
SEEN AS MORE INFORMATION COMES
OUT TO US THAT WE PASS IT ON TO
THEM. SO I HAD A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS IN THE AREA OF
LICENSING ENFORCEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION. AND THAT MAYBE
I COULD START WITH WHAT THE ONE
THAT SAID. THE MOST DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO ANSWER WHEN SOMEONE
TALKS TO ME ABOUT IT AND THAT'S
THE- REQUIREMENT OF UP TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS. OF
TRAINING NECESSARY. AND I THINK
YOU BROKE IT DOWN. A FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS FOR HAIR SIXTEEN
HUNDRED FOR COSMETOLOGY IS THAT
RIGHT SOMETHING TO THAT. AND I
KNOW THAT THEIR- AND I THINK
YOU SPOKE TO THAT THAT'S TEN
MONTHS FULL TIME. RIGHT SO TO
BE A POLICE OFFICER IN OUR
STATE. REQUIRES ABOUT HALF OF
THAT. AMOUNT OF TRAINING. TO BE
A POLICE OFFICER. I DON'T KNOW
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
WHO IS A GREAT FRIEND ONLINE
FORCING KNEW THAT. THAT WILL
REQUIRE IN IN THE COSMETOLOGY
AREAS. IS TRAINING TWICE THAT
OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
CARRIES A GUN. CAN YOU CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT THAT ISSUE AND I
EACH SHARED THE IMPORTANT WORK
THAT IS DONE ON A PERSON'S FACE
FOR SKIN AND ON THEIR HAIR ON
THEIR NAILS BUT CAN YOU HELP ME
WITH THE PERSON ON THE STREET
HE SAYS A STEVE I'D LIKE TO GET
INTO THIS FIELD BUT IT'S GONNA
TAKE ME AND AS YOU DESCRIBE IT
TEN MONTHS FULL TIME. AN
AVERAGE OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN THESE ARE TUITION.
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
SOMEONE'S HAIR CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT. YES AS A LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST I DO KNOW THAT IN
COMING IN CONTACT WITH THE
PUBLIC OR PERSON. WE ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO DIFFERENT
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND SO
ESTATE IT WHEN YOU HAVE. WHEN
YOU'RE WORKING ON MULTIPLE
PEOPLE IN THIS ONLINE
ENVIRONMENT THEN THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY LENTILS ARE NOT
DISINFECTED ARE CLEANED
PROPERLY. OF CAUSING INFECTION
AND S AS I LISTED IN MY
PORTION OF MY OVERVIEW THERE
ARE SO MANY COMPLAINTS THAT WE
GET FROM INFECTIONS THAT CAUSE
HARM TO INDIVIDUALS AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO BE AWARE. OF THOSE
POSSIBILITIES NOT JUST FOR THE
HARM THAT CAN COME TO THEIR
CLIENT BUT ALSO PERSONALLY. WE
DID DO AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
COSMETOLOGY PROGRAM I FIFTEEN
HUNDRED OUR COSMETOLOGY PROGRAM
KNOWING THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WITHIN A
COSMETOLOGY PROGRAM COVER NOT
ONLY HAIR STYLING. ALSO MANY
CARING AND IS THAT IT. AND
WITHIN THAT ROOM OVER TODAY. IS
THE SIXTEEN HOUR COURSE NOT
VERY. AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
INTERESTED IN HAIR STYLING AND
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE LOOKED AT IN DEPTH.
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO PRACTICES NOT ONLY
BARBERING BUT COSMETOLOGY. WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE BIOLOGY
OF AN INDIVIDUAL THAT
ADDITIONAL TRAINING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- AS I'VE
ALREADY STATED THAT YEAH. Q.
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE A TODAY
MAYBE AND JUST AND FOLLOW UP
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND IT'S A-
DEATH IT'S NOT AN EASY QUESTION
ANSWER TODAY BUT- WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS AND YOU TALK ABOUT
INFECTION AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT AND CERTAINLY NOTHING I
WOULD EVER ARGUE WITH BUT- SO.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF WITHIN
THAT SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS HOW
MUCH IS DEDICATED TO THE ISSUE
OF INFECTION I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT. WERE IN FRONT OF ME LIKE
THAT THAT NUMBER OF HOURS IF
YOU KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER. I
BELIEVE IT'S A BROWN'S AM
HEALTH AND SAFETY USUALLY
COVERS AND MENTOR COURSES
AROUND TWO HUNDRED TO FOUR
HUNDRED HOURS. OKAY SO TWO
HUNDRED HOURS THIS IS LAWS AND
REGULATIONS DISINFECTION AND
SANITATION. OTHER AREAS SO THAT
SOUNDS LIKE BETWEEN TEN AND 20%
OF THE EDUCATION WELL IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO ME MAYBE FOR MY
COLLEAGUES TO. UNDERSTAND THAT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOUR
REQUIREMENT EXACTLY WHAT THE
TRAINING THAT GOES INTO THAT SO
WE COULD MORE CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW. SOMEBODY
SAYS TO ME HEY STEVE I WANT TO
TAKE CARE OF SOMEONE'S HAIR I
THINK I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING BUT
I. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I DO
IT RIGHT. IT'S A PRETTY BIG
BARRIER SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS
TEN MONTHS RIGHT. CORRECT YEAH
SO THAT WOULD IT WOULD HELP
ILLUMINATE THE ARC OUR
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD IS
TO UNDERSTAND THAT. THE
SPECIFICS OF THAT EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT OKAY. I'M
INTERESTED AND A YOU HAVE A SET
THE- SINCE PART OF THIS WORLD
THAT YOU'RE IN AND I'M SURE YOU
DEAL. WITH IT ON SEVEN A LEVELS
IN THE PERSON. SOMEONE OPERATE
WITHOUT A- YOU GIVE US A CAN
YOU GIVE THE ARE COMMITTEES A
SENSE OF. OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES OUTSIDE OF A
LICENSE ESTABLISHMENT YOU HAVE
ANY SENSE OF THAT. WE DON'T
FIND A LOT OF UNLICENSED
ESTABLISHMENT USUALLY THEY ARE
PRETTY GOOD IT PLANE FOR. THE
BUSINESS LICENSE THAT COVERS
THE ENTIRE SALON AND IT'S A
FIFTY DOLLAR APPLICATION FEE SO
WHEN WE DO FIND AMONG LICENSE
THAT PRETTY WILLING TO GET THAT
SHOP LICENSE RIGHT AWAY. WE DO
FIND UNLICENSED INDIVIDUALS
WORKING IN PHONE LINES AM I
DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS IN FRONT
OF ME ON THAT BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING WE CAN
PROVIDE TO THE COMMITTEES. IS
THERE ANY PARTICULAR PLACE THAT
THAT YOU SEE MORE ACTIVITY IN
THE SAY I'M LICENSE SPACE THAN
OTHERS. NOT REALLY. WE
DEFINITELY. SEE LESS AND WE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS VERY HAS
OF MUCH HIGHER POPULATION IN
GENERAL SO WE DEFINITELY ARE
SEEN MORE IN THE AND LOS
ANGELES AREA BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MANY MORE SALONS IN THAT AREA
AND WE DON'T SEE IT AS MUCH UP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT WE
SEE IT. WE SEE IT AS WELL. SO I
GUESS IT'S A LOT EASIER TO HAVE
TO SEE IT AND ENFORCEMENT ISSUE
WHEN SOMEONE PUTS A- GETS A
BRICK AND MORTAR ESTABLISH AND
PUTS A SIGN OUT AND GETS A
BUSINESS LICENSE OF SOME KIND.
RIGHT BUT BUT WHAT ABOUT THOSE
WHO PRACTICE THAT THEIR WORK IN
SOMEONE'S HOME THE HAVE ANY
SENSE OF FAT. HOW BIG OF AN
ISSUE IT IS. THAT THAT I'M
LICENSE ACTIVITY. WE MIGHT BE
ABLE WE MIGHT HAVE DATA ON THAT
BECAUSE WE DO. GET COMPLAINTS
ABOUT AND LICENSE ACTIVITY IN
AREAS OTHER THAN SALONS AND WE
DO HAVE THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE
TO HAVE HOMES THE ONES AS WELL
SO THERE WE DO HAVE QUITE A
QUITE A FEW IN CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE WHO HAVE. SORT OF
TRANSITION PART OF THEIR HOME
INTO A SALON WHICH IS TOTALLY
ACCEPTABLE AND SO WE HAVE HOME
SALONS THAT ARE LEGITIMATE AS
AS WELL BUT I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS ON EXACTLY HOW MANY
COMPLAINTS WE RECEIVE OF
UNLICENSED WORKERS I DON'T
THINK IT'LL HIGH EARLIER TODAY
IN THE TESTIMONY I THINK I
HEARD THAT THAT THAT MAY BE
REFERRING TO LAST YEAR FORTY
TWO HUNDRED CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS. THAT I HEAR THAT SO
OF THOSE FORTY TWO HUNDRED
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS HOW MANY
WERE THE- INVOLVED IN ON
LICENSE INDIVIDUAL GENERA. AM I
DO NOT KNOW AM. I WOULD I WOULD
DEFINITELY SAY THE HIGH NUMBER.
YOU'VE DONE A LEVIN THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS ACT BUT JUST IF IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO GET THAT
DETAIL IF YOU HAVE IT ON THE
COMPLAINTS ELEVEN THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS LAST YEAR DID I
HEAR THAT CORRECTLY IT'S A LOT
OF INSPECTIONS HOW BIG OF A
ENFORCEMENT TEAM YOU HAVE TO DO
ELEVEN THOUSAND INSPECTIONS WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE INSPECTORS AND
THAT TO COVER ABOUT FORTY SIX
THOUSAND A MONTH HAVE THOSE
ELEVEN THOUSAND INSPECTIONS
THAT WERE DONE DO YOU KNOW AN
OFF HAND HOW MANY WERE OF THE
NINE LICENSES SOLIDITY OR ON
LICENSE INDIVIDUAL. I DON'T
HAVE THOSE NUMBERS ON HIM BUT
THAT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING IN
OUR SYSTEM THAT WE COULD PULL
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A LOT
EASIER ONCE AGAIN TO GO AFTER
IT ESTABLISHMENTS BUT AT. E. L.
EIGHT. I'M TRYING TO GET MY
HANDS OUT OF THE ON LICENSE
COMMUNITY OUT THERE AND IS IT
ANY. AGAIN IS THE INSPECTIONS A
DATA POINT TO LOOK AT IN TERMS
OF. LICENSE BUSINESSES. WHEN
OUR INSPECTORS DO GO OUT THEY
KIND OF FOCUS ON AN AREA SO IF
AN INSPECTOR GOES OUT TO A
SPECIFIC LOCATION THEY'LL
USUALLY TRY TO COVER ANYTHING
CLOSE IN THAT AREA SO THAT'S
WHERE WE WOULD FIND SOME
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY IF WE FIND
AN UNLICENSED ESTABLISHMENT. M.
AND AGAIN WE WOULD DEFINITELY
HAVE THOSE NUMBERS IN OUR IN
OUR SYSTEM THAT WE COULD PULL.
OKAY WOULD BE HELPFUL TO TRY I
MEAN I'M TRYING TO GET A HANDLE
ON IT I HOPE THAT YOU GUYS
COULD I GET A HAND HOW BIG OF A
PROBLEM IS IT. YEAH WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THE CANNABIS WORLD AND
TALK ABOUT THE LICENSE CANNABIS
WORLD IN THE UNLICENSED CAB GET
OUT OF THIS WORLD. AND HOW BIG
OF A SUCCESS OR FAILURE WERE
HAVING IN GETTING WITHIN THE
LICENSE SPACE. I'D BE GOOD IF
YOU COULD HAVE THAT SENSE TO
ENSURE THAT WITH US HOW BIG OF
A PROBLEM IS IT. OF PEOPLE
OPERATING WITHOUT A LICENSE.
AND HOW ARE THEY DOING IT. AND
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO I THINK
TO US. EARLIER YOU TALKED ABOUT
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT ARE DONE
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND YOU
MENTION PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
AND YOU SPEND SOMETIME TALKING
IMPORTANTLY ABOUT. PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
EXPLOITED THEY'RE WORKING AT IT
IN FACT IF THE WORK TO CLOSE
THEM DOWN DO YOU HAVE ANY
BREAKDOWN AS TO HOW MUCH OF
THAT. TRAINING IS DONE BETWEEN
PRIVATE. INSTITUTIONS AND
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS. WE HAVE
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
APPROVED SCHOOLS AND I BELIEVE
LESS THAN TEN OF THOSE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND AS THE
BOARD YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT IF THE
STUDENT CAN GET THAT TYPE OF
TRAINING AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE GONNA SAY THE HECK
OF A LOT OF MONEY. RIGHT AND
OPTIONS AND PERHAPS GET EVEN A
BETTER EDUCATION. WHAT WORK IS
THE BOARD DOWN TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS TO. BE MORE ACTIVE
IN AND THIS TYPE OF EDUCATION
WORK. WE HAVEN'T NECESSARILY
WORKED WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT DON'T OFFER THE
COSMETOLOGY PROGRAM WE'VE
WORKED WITH THE ONES THAT THAT
DO. BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE ANY
OUTRAGE TO OTHER CAN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT ARE NOT OFFERING
THAT THE PROGRAMS IT SOUNDS
LIKE AS YOU DESCRIBE IT THAT
OUR OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
PROVIDE LESS THAN 10% MAYBE
EVEN FIVE PERCENT. OF THE
TRAINING IN THIS AREA SUCH A
REASONABLE RIGHT INCLUSION FROM
WHAT SHE SAID. AND YET YOU HAVE
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
LICENSEES. SALADA PEOPLE
WORKING IN THE SPACE. IT SEEMS
THAT IF WE HAVE A MUTUAL
INTEREST MAKING SURE PEOPLE ARE
TRAINED RIGHT AND YOU TALKED
ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF THE
PROBLEMS YOU ENCOUNTER WITH
SCHOOLS THAT ARE DOING IT RIGHT.
AND WE HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE IN
OUR PBLIC INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE
WE HAVE SOME AUTHORITY OVER
WHAT THEY DO. AND WHEN PEOPLE
TALK TO BE ABOUT HOW DO WE GET
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM TO BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO WHAT PEOPLE WANT
TO DO AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THEY MAY SEE. ECONOMICALLY JUST
SEEMS LIKE MAYBE THIS IS A
SPACE THAT WE SHOULD BE MORE
ACTIVE THAN. MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN ABOUT FURTHER.
I CERTAINLY WOULD RATHER SE
OUR COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
OFFERING THESE PROGRAMS AND
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS NOT TO
THEIR- DETRIMENT BUT HEY YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT
EFFICIENT. RIGHT EFFECTIVE WAY
FOR PEOPLE TO. IMPROVE THEIR-
ECONOMIC. PROSPECTS AND
CERTAINLY IN THE IN THE BARBARY
AND COSMETOLOGY FEEL GIVEN HOW
MANY PEOPLE UTILIZE IT IT SEEMS
LIKE. WE MAYBE IF WE MAY. WE
MAY BE FALLING SHORT I'D LOVE
TO HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSION. ON
THAT. YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T
TALKED MUCH ABOUT TATTOO
ARTISTS THEY'RE THEY'RE IN YOUR
PURVIEW ONE DAY THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE NOT IN YOUR FOR YOU.
TWO CUPS TATTOOS. I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S A DC A BOARD
THAT COVERS TIED TO THE BELIEVE
IT FALLS THAT LOOK ON LOCAL AND
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. REALLY. WELL
IT SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF
A MANIPULATION OF SKIN. DEATH
I'D BE INTERESTED IN ANY
THOUGHTS THAT YOU HAVE AS A
BOARD AS TO WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD BE MORE ATTENTIVE TO
THAT ISSUE FROM THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY POINT OF VIEW. SO MAYBE
THAT'S ANOTHER FOLLOW UP BY
ISSUE THAT ARE STATUS CANNELLA.
CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WE EL WE TALK A LOT IN
OUR COMMITTEE ABOUT BEST
PRACTICES AND- I'M WONDERING IF
YOU COULD SHARE ANY THOUGHTS
THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT HOW THE
BOARD OR THE STAFF. LOOKS TO
OTHER STATES RATHER COUNTRIES
IN TERMS OF BEST PRACTICES IN
THIS AREA BE DONE ANY THOUGHT
ANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVE. WE M. I. ATTENDS THE
NATIONAL CONFERENCE WHERE. GOOD
PORTION OF THE STATE'S GET
TOGETHER AND DISCUSS KIND OF
COMMON ISSUES THAT WE'RE ALL
HAVING THEM WE'VE DEFINITELY
LOOKED IT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH A LOT OF OTHER STATES ON
SOME RECIPROCITY ISSUES THAT
WE'RE HAVING IN THE SELLING OF
OURS THAT WE EXPERIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA. SO WE WE'VE WORKED
WITH A LOT OF OTHER STATES ON
THAT ASPECT BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING SO MANY FRAUDULENT
CERTIFICATION LETTERS COMING IN
FROM OTHER STATES OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET LICENSE TO BE A
RECIPROCITY WITH FRAUDULENT
DOCUMENTS SO THERE'S THAT
ASPECT WE HAVE ALSO LOOKED AT
OTHER STATES FOR THEIR- THERE'S
SOME OF THEM EDUCATION AS YOU
MENTIONED THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS. M. AND I'M ACTUALLY
GOING IT THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE AND NEXT WEEK AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE A MAJOR
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION DURING THAT
AS WELL I AM MOST STATES ARE
AROUND FIFTEEN TO SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS THERE ARE SOME
STATES THAT WERE MUCH HIGHER
THAN THAT THAT ARE WORKING TO
REDUCE THEIR HOURS DOWN TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OR SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS WE HAD A COUPLE
STATES OF TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
HOURS. I AM SO IT'S DEFINITELY
A DISCUSS WITH LIKE THE STATE
COME TOGETHER TO BE. CLOSER M.
AT THE OUT. IT'S THE THOUGHT
PROCESS A BETTER THROUGHOUT THE
DIFFERENT STATES. AND IF YOU
ADD SO I'D BE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THAT TYPE OF COMPARISON
THAT NOT JUST IN TERMS OF FIVE
HOURS AND KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
DISCUSSION OF OURS IS NOT ABOUT
A- STATE TO DEREGULATE. IT'S
REALLY ABOUT HOW WE PROVIDE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AND ARE
THERE BARRIERS FAIR BARRIERS.
UNFAIR BARRIERS TO ACCESS. AND
SO I WOULD BE INTERESTED AND
YOUR- IDEA WORK ON BEST
PRACTICES A BAND BEYOND THE
ISSUE OF OURS. AND WE HAD A
HEARING A FEW WEEKS AGO.
DEALING WITH SERVICE MEMBERS
WHO WERE TRANSFERRED. AND HOW
THE HOW CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH
THE SPOUSES OF SERVICE MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT
TRANSFER. COULD BE LIMITED BY
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AND A
LACK OF RECIPROCITY. HAVE YOU
AND THE BOARD HAVE ANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT. WHETHER
THAT'S AN ISSUE AND OR WHETHER
OR NOT THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SPECIAL ACCOMMODATIONS THAT YOU
COULD BE PROVIDING SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEIR SPOUSES THAT.
ARE IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE. WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY ISSUES WHEN IT
COMES TO RECIPROCITY MOST
PEOPLE COMING FROM OTHER STATES
SPECIALLY IN IN THE SERVICE
AREA. ARE USUALLY IMMEDIATELY
QUALIFY FOR OUR LICENSE HERE WE
PUT ANYONE WE HAVE THE
QUESTIONS ON OUR APPLICATIONS
AS WELL AS OUR ONLINE FORMS OF
THEIR PART OF THE MILITARY OR
IF THEY HAVE A SPOUSE THAT THE
MILITARY. AND WE EXPECT THEIR
APPLICATIONS AND PROCESS THEM
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY SO WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY CONCERNS WITH
THAT AT ALL WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
PUT THAT AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST
TO PROCESS THEM. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S EASILY SEEN ON
THE WEB PAGE. ONE WHO'S CALLING
FROM MARYLAND INCOME IF YOU'RE
FROM ARKANSAS AND THEY LOOK AT
YOUR- INFORMATION IS A PRETTY
CLEAR THAT HAVE AN EXPEDITED
PROCESS THAT WE DO WE HAVE A
MILITARY BUTTON ON OUR- ON OUR
HOME. INTO THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR.
BLACK COLLEGE. HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT
DURING PORTENT ME JUST FINISH
UP BY ASKING ABOUT THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHERS WHO I
REGULARLY INTERACT WITH YOUR
BOARD I DO FIND THAT IS WHO ARE
THE FOLKS THAT THAT THAT
CONNECTED YOU COME TO YOUR
MEETINGS PAY ATTENTION ARE THEY-
BY THE LICENSEES ARE THERE ARE
THEY ADVOCATES FOR LICENSEES
WHO WHO ARE THAT POWERFUL
FORCES THAT COME AND YOUR
WORLD. IN THE WORK THAT YOU DO.
CHECK OF COURSE SO HE HAS A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ATTEND OUR
MEETINGS REGULARLY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. TRAJAN'S
TRANSGRESSION OF BEAUTY HI
FEDERATION ANY TRAFFIC FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATICS ALLIANCE AND
WE HAD. A HANDFUL AS LOCAL
LICENSEES OR SCHOOL OWNERS WHO
WILL COME. BY AND FREQUENTLY I
REGULARLY MEET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE. WHO WORKS WITH
PRIMARILY VIETNAMESE AMERICAN.
KERRISON SALONS SHE MOVED THEM
TO MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PRACTICES. FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND SO THAT'S A
GROUP THAT I REGULARLY MEET
WITH. ON MY OWN TIME AND THEY
ACTUALLY DID. ATTEND OUR LAST
BREATH MEETING AS WELL. OKAY
LET ME JUST ASK ONE FINAL
FOLLOW UP. AND THIS GOES BACK
TO THE CURRICULUM AND
EXAMINATIONS WHEN IS THE LAST
TIME YOU CHANGE YOUR
EXAMINATION. HOW OFTEN IS IT
BEEN A IMPROVED OR CHANGED. WE
UTILIZE THE NATIONAL EXAM SO
IT'S UPDATED EVERY THREE TO
FIVE YEARS THEY'RE CURRENTLY
THE MORE ALSO WE ALSO DO OUR
OWN OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS AS
WELL AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
NATIONAL EXAM IS I AM STILL
ACCURATE AND VALID WE JUST
RECENTLY DID A REVIEW OF THE
NATIONAL COSMETOLOGY EXAM AND
WORK IN THE PROCESS OF DOING A
REVIEW OF THE- BARBERINI EXAM
IS AN ELECTORAL GOP NEXT SO.
THE NATIONAL EXAM DOES REGULATE
THEM UP ON A REGULAR SCHEDULE
AND THEN WE ALSO WORKWITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO ENSURE THAT. WHAT THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION IS DOING
IS ACCURATE WHAT ABOUT THE
PRACTICAL EXAM THE DELUDE IN
MINISTRY WE ADMINISTER IT BUT
IT'S STABLE DEVELOPED. BY THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ACTUAL AM. THE CRITICAL
STANDARDS FOR THE EXAMINATION
SITES MAY COME OUT AND A TRAIN
OUR EXAMINERS. ON A ANNUAL
BASIS M. SO IT'S IN THE SAME
UPDATING PROCESS AS IT IS WITH
ANY OF THE IT THE WHOLE EXAM.
GOOD AND DO YOU GET ALL THE
RESOURCES YOU NEED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO YOUR WORK
CURRENT LIMITATIONS THAT AND
PUT ON ON YOUR WORK FROM.
BUDGETARY OR OTHERS THAT FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION WE'D WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY LIMITATIONS ANY
LEGAL LIMITATIONS THAT I
CREATED YOU DON'T HAVE YOUR OWN
ATTORNEYS RIGHT THAT ATTORNEYS
PROVIDED TO YOU. AN ATTORNEY IS
PROVIDED TO US YES IN ANY
LIMITATIONS THERE AND YOUR
ABILITY ACCESS LEGAL ADVICE AND
IN THEM AND YOU IN YOUR WORK
NOT AT ALL NOT AT ALL OKAY
COULD YOU HEAR. ALL RIGHT THAT
THAT FINISH MY QUESTION SAYS
SENATOR ARCHULETA THE FOLLOW UP
THANK YOU FOR LIKE MRS SO MANY
ASPECTS OF YOUR INDUSTRY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I DON'T THINK
WE DID COVER. WAS AN ASSISTANT
TO SELL ONE THAT YOU MAY HAVE
WORKING AND GET BIT YOU HAVE
YOUR SISTER. TAKE THE HAIR HAVE
YOUR SYSTEM TO THIS PARTY. YOUR
POINT WITH ASSISTING CROP PINE.
ACTUALLY THEWORK OF SOMEONE
THEY SHOULD BE LICENSED IN HOW
DO YOU OVERSEE THAT. DON'T HAVE
AN ASSISTANT PER SE ABILITY IN
OUR IN OUR STATUTE RIGHT NOW WE
DO HAVE APPRENTICES AND AN
APPRENTICE IS A LICENSED
INDIVIDUAL WHO WORKS FOR THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED HOURS SO TWO YEARS
THEY'RE DOING ON THE JOB
TRAINING IN A SENSE WORKING IN
A SALON. A LOT OF SALONS SE
THEM AS AN ASSISTANT BUT THEY
HAVE TO BE SUPERVISED AT ALL
TIMES BY A LICENSEE I AM SO
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF THE WAY
WE HAVE THAT. A LOT OF SALONS
WILL HIRE WHAT THEY REFER TO AS
AN ASSISTANT BUT ACCORDING TO
OUR BOARD THERE ARE FULLY
LICENSED INDIVIDUAL. SURE IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THE MOST
ASSISTANCE. ARE LICENSED AND OR
STUDENTS TO GO ON AND FURTHER
THEIR CAREER. OKAY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. WELL VERY GOOD I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOU AND YOUR GOOD WORK AS A
CHAIR LOW IS INDICATED TO THE
PUBLIC MEMBERS ACT YOU DON'T
GET A LOT OF THE SEPTA.
APPRECIATION FOR THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT YOU DO IN THE
PROFESSION AND WE THANK YOU FOR
THAT AS A MENTION AT THE AT THE
START THIS IS THE FIRST IN A
SERIES OPEN TO DO A HEARING IN
IN THE FALL FOR THE WITH THE
SUPPORT OF CHAIR LOW TO A
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION. I
DO WANNA WRITE UP BY FOLKS WHO
MIGHT WANT TO SHARE SOME
TESTIMONY PROFESSIONAL GROUPS
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
STAFFS I AM PARTICULARLY YOU'VE
HEARD MIKE QUESTIONS YOU KNOW
WHAT IT IS OF INTEREST THAT
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
ISSUE OF THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS. AND THE TRAINING THAT
REALLY GET DETAILS THAT REALLY
GO TO THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT TO THAT THAT THAT
CONTINUING CONVERSATION TO
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA. THIS BATTLE I.
FIGHT. A GROUP IS A. COME ON UP
TO LEAD TO SHARE THEIR THEIR
THOUGHTS AS WE- COMPLETE OUR
HEARING. WELCOME PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF TO CHAIR
MEMBERS FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF
THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA. A NON
LICENSEE. THE JUST BRIEF
BACKGROUND THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY FEDERATION WAS FORMED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. BY
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS THAT WERE
CONCERNED THAT SACRAMENTO IS
DOING MORE THINGS TO US RATHER
THAN FOR US TO BE CANDID. MAN
THAT THERE WAS IN THE UNITED
VOICE FOR ALL THE VARIOUS
SECTORS OF OUR INDUSTRY
SPEAKING ABOUT ISSUES. AND SEND
IT IMPORTANCE THAT THE INDUSTRY
CAN REACH A LARGE CONSENSUS ON.
SO THE MISSION OF MY
ORGANIZATION IS SIMPLE TO RAISE
THE PROFESSIONALISM OF BEAUTY
IN CALIFORNIA WE FIGURE A
RISING TIDE LIFTS ALL SHIPS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME
TRENDS IN OUR INDUSTRY THAT GO
AGAINST THAT. AND THE WHOLE
TOUCH UPON THOSE BRIEFLY. BUT I
TRY MY BEST IN IN TWENTY YEARS
I BY THE WAY I WAS BROUGHT ON
TWO THOUSAND. TOTAL FOR
NINETEEN YEARS I'VE REPRESENTED
THIS INDUSTRY. AND I'VE MISSED
ONE STATE BOARD MEETING IN
TWENTY YEARS. SO I'VE BEEN A
DILIGENT ADVOCATE FOR THIS
INDUSTRY MY BOARD MEMBERS
REPRESENT EVERY SECTOR OF THE
INDUSTRY. INCLUDING SCHOOLS
INDIVIDUAL LICENSEES
INDEPENDENT SALONS CHAIN SALONS
INDIVIDUAL US PRINTERS WITCHER
ESSENTIALLY SOLE PROPRIETORS.
ALL SECTORS PLACE IN SECTORS OF
THE INDUSTRY. MONDAY NIGHT FOR
EXAMPLE I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SPEAKING TO A FEW HUNDRED SALON
OWNERS ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THROUGH A LIVE WEBCAST IS
DEFINITIONS SENT SHOCK WAVES.
THROUGH OUR INDUSTRY. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I WANTED. TO
EXPRESS TO YOU ALL TODAY. OUR
INDUSTRY HAS REALLY SEEN
UPHEAVAL COMING FROM SACRAMENTO
HUGE CHANGES AND NOT TO
SACRAMENTO FROM THE STATE
SUPREME COURT IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. FIVE YEARS AGO IT WAS
CODIFIED AND CLARIFIED THAT
COMMISSION WAGES FOR EMPLOYEES
IS ESSENTIALLY ILLEGAL AS WE
PRACTICE IT AND AS OUR INDUSTRY
IT'S PRACTICE DID. SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL. BECAUSE AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN CLARIFIES THAT IF YOU
ARE SELLING YOUR OWN SERVICES
AS OPPOSED TO SOMEONE ELSE'S
PRODUCT OR SERVICES YOU CANNOT
RECEIVE COMMISSIONS. AND AB
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN FIVE YEARS AGO
CREATED A PIECE RATE STRUCTURE
WHICH IS VERY COMPLICATED TO
IMPLEMENT IN A SALON SETTING
ESSENTIALLY EVERYONE OF OUR
STYLIST HAS TO CHECK IN AND
CHECK OUT EVERY TIME THEY GO ON
A BREAK EVERY TIME THEY GO ON
LUNCH. EVERY TIME THEY'RE NOT
PROVIDING ACTIVE SERVICE.
BECAUSE THE INTENT OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN WAS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT FOR SO LONG
INDIVIDUAL STYLIST RECEIVING A
PIECE OF THEIR SERVICES. IN
TERMS OF PAY. THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE HARMED FOR IT LEGAL
BREAKS OR WE SEE THE SAME
COMMENSURATE PAY WHEN THEY'RE
NOT ACTUALLY DOING A SERVICE
BUT STILL UNDER THE EMPLOYEE
AND CONTROLLED THEIR SALON
OWNER. THAT HAS BEEN A VERY BIG
MUCH FOR EMPLOYER BASED SALONS.
HOWEVER AT LEAST THREE QUARTERS
OF OUR SALONS ARE NOT EMPLOYER
BASED THEIR BOOTH RENTAL OR
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. SO THEY
A SKATE THE RECENT UPHEAVAL
REGARDING THE LACK OF BEING
ABLE TO PAY COMMISSIONS.
DYNAMAX COMES ALOG A YEAR AGO
LAST APRIL IN A PEACEFUL FOR
BOOTH RENTAL HUGE CHANGE COMING
DOWN THE PIKE CLEARLY THE STATE
REGULATORS. AT T. D. I. R. IT
CETERA HAVE NOT REALLY ACTED
UPON DYNAMIX WAITING FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE AND THE
POLICY MAKING BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT YOU ALL TO ACT FIRST.
IF AND WHEN AB FIVE BECOME
STATUTE. EVENTUALLY THE STATE
REGULATORS WILL START ENFORCING
DYNAMICS AND THE BE PART OF
DYNAMAX ESSENTIALLY OUTLAWS
ALMOST EVERY FORM OF FINAL AS
CURRENTLY PRACTICED IN OUR
INDUSTRY AND AGAIN AS I STATED
EARLIER THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
SALONS. UTILIZED TRAINERS SO
THIS IS AN ERA OF MAJOR CHANGE
TORE INDUSTRY. I WOULD CAUTION
WITH ALL DUE HUMILITY AND
RESPECT FOR THE WORK THESE TWO
JOINT COMMITTEES ARE DOING. TO
AVOID THE TEMPTATION OF SENDING
EVEN MORE DRAMATIC REFORMS ARE
WAY. THE STATE BOARD IS YOU
HEARD ENGAGING WITH INDUSTRY
HAS WORKED FOR TWO YEARS AMPLE
MANNER RESPONSIBLE MEANS
CREATING FREELANCE LICENSE
OUTSIDE. STATUTES THE PERSONAL
SERVICE. THAT WAS A HUGE LEFT
FOR OUR INDUSTRY HOW DO YOU
MAINTAIN PLAYABILITY CURRENTS
FOR EXAMPLE AND VERY FIRST
TUMORS WHEN THE SERVICES AREN'T
EVEN BEING DONE IN A LICENSED
ESTABLISHMENT THAT CAN BE
INSPECTED. INSPECTORS
DEFINITIONS THE THOSE. SO
LIABILITY INSURANCE IS ACTUALLY
INCLUDED IN THE REGULATORY
LANGUAGE FOR PERSONAL SERVICE
PERMIT. APPLICATIONS RECOGNIZE
ESSENTIALLY THERE'S NO WAY THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO INSPECT THOSE
SERVICES OUTSIDE OF BRICK AND
MORTAR AND SO AT THE VERY LEAST
THEY COULD REQUIRE THEM TO HAVE
MINIMUM GENERAL AND
PROFESSIONAL LIABILITY
INSURANCE SO I BELIEVE THE
STATE BOARD HAS BEEN
RESPONSIBLE. IN TACKLING THAT
TOUGH ISSUE I KNOW IT'S A
PRIORITY OF A CHAIRMAN LOW.
WITH THE GIG ECONOMY IT CETERA.
AND I DO WANNA SEE WORD ABOUT
THE STATE BOARD WHEN I STARTED
REPRESENTING THIS INDUSTRY
NINETEEN YEARS AGO WE DIDN'T
HAVE A BOARD THEN IT WAS A
BUREAU OF A FEW YEARS LATER WE-
A SPONSORED LEGISLATION SENATOR
POLANCO TO BRING BACK THE STATE
BOARD STRUCTURE. THE REASON WAS
A STATE BOARD HAS TO DO ALL
THEIR WORK IN PUBLIC ALL OF
THEIR HEARINGS OUR LIVE WEBCAST
IT AN ARCHIVE YOU CAN. SEE ALL
OF THOSE HEARINGS YOU'LL SEE A
LOT OF MY RECEDING HAIRLINE
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS IN
EACH OF THOSE WEBCASTS. I
ORGANIZATION DOES NOT. THE
GENDER WE WERE CONCERNED OTHERS
DID TWENTY PLUS YEARS AGO A
STATE BOARD STRUCTURE BRINGS
THE SUNLIGHT UPON THESE
REGULATORY AGENCIES AND MY
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTS THAT SO
EVERYTHING I'VE EVER SAID OR
ANY OF MY MEMBERS OR ANYBODY
FROM THE INDUSTRY IS RECORDED
LIVE FOR PEOPLE TO KNOW WHAT
THEY STAND FOR AND I THINK THAT
IN AND OF ITSELF HAS BEEN A
PIVOTAL IN CHANGING THE MAKEUP
OF THIS BOARD AND THEIR
OPERATIONS WHEN I STARTED
REPRESENTING THIS INDUSTRY. IT
TOOK ON AVERAGE EIGHT MONTHS
FOR A GRADUATE TO TAKE THE
LICENSING EXAM SO YOU MENTIONED
THE EIGHT TO TEN MONTHS IT
TAKES FOR SCHOOLING IMAGINE
WAITING EQUALLY LONG. JUST TO
BE TAPPED FOR THE EXAM. SO THE
WORK OF THE STATE BOARD.
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WHO'S BEEN A
LONG TERM MEMBER OF THE STATE
BOARD AND I WISH WE COULD PASS
A LOT OF FORCE HER TO CONTINUE
WORKING FOR THE CITY BOARD. IN
THE GREAT STATE BOARD MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPORTED
CLOTHING THE TWO THAT WERE HERE
BEFORE YOU CHANGED ALL OF THAT.
AND SO THERE IS NO WAIT TIME.
FOR AN EXAMINATION. THE SAME
FOR SALON OWNERS IT WOULD TAKE
EIGHT TEN MONTHS FOR THEM TO
HAVE AN APPEAL HEARING ON ANY
CITATION GIVEN BY ONE OF THE
STATE BOARD INSPECTORS WHICH BY
THE WAY WHEN I FIRST STARTED
REPRESENT IN THIS INDUSTRY THE
INSPECTORS NOT ONLY GAVE THE
INSPECTION REPORT THE ATTACHED
A MONETARY SANCTION. AT THE
TIME OF THE INSPECTION. THE
WORKING WITH STATE BOARD STAFF
OVER THE YEARS. THEY'VE CHANGED
ALL THAT SO NOW A STATE BOARD
INSPECTOR ONLY GIVES
INSPECTIONS REPORTS INCLUDING
PHOTOGRAPHIC EVIDENCE AND THEY
SUBMIT THAT TO SACRAMENTO'S
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WHO LOOK
AT THE HISTORY OF THAT LICENSEE
WHO LOOK AT THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE INFRACTIONS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO COMMUNICATE
BEFORE A MONETARY SANCTION IS
EVER ATTACHED. THAT KINDA DUE
PROCESS IT'S JUST ONE OF A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT EXAMPLES OF
WHAT I'D SAY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS BY THE STATE
BOARD. TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY
AND TO PROTECT CONSUMERS IN A.
AB HELPFUL WAY LET'S JUST PUT
IT THAT WAY SO WE'VE BEEN VERY
GRATEFUL FOR MARK ASSOCIATIONS
VANTAGE POINT OF OUR STATE
BOARD AND THEIR SERVICES TO OUR
INDUSTRY AND TO PROTECTING OUR-
CLIENTELE. I DO WNT TO HIT
UPON BARRIERS TO ENTRY I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN A CONCERN SB NINE
NINE NINE WAS INTRODUCED LAST
YEAR SENATOR NGUYEN HAD THE
BILL THE YEAR BEFORE THAT OTHER
STATES ARE LOOKING AT CHIPPING
AWAY AT LICENSE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE SUMMER BY THE WAY JUST
TRYING TO OBLITERATE. LICENSING
ALTOGETHER. THAT MOVEMENT IS A
LIBERTARIAN MOVEMENT AGAINST
VOCATIONAL LICENSING THEY'VE
LOOKED YOU KNOW SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE IT USED TO BE LESS
THAN 10% OF THE WORKFORCE WAS
LICENSED NOW IT'S PUSHING ONE
THIRD AND SO THE LIBERTARIAN
STRING SAYS THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THAT WHY IS
GOVERNMENT HAVING TO GET IN THE
WAY OF YOU MAKING A LIVING. TO
GIVE YOU PERMISSION. BY WILL
COTTON MEMBERS TO LOOK AT THAT
HISTORY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF PRIVATE SECTOR
UNIONIZATION. IT'S BEEN EXACTLY
AN INVERSE INVERSE PROPORTIONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH LICENSING IN
OTHER WORDS. AS UNIONS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR HAVE DECLINED
MEMBERSHIP IN PERCENTAGE OF
OVERALL WORK FORCE. LICENSING
HAS FILLED THE GAP AS IT WERE.
UNIONS USED TO MAINTAIN A LOT
OF THE STANDARDS IN THESE
LOCATIONS THROUGH THEIR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AT
SETTER. AS THEY HAVE ATROPHIED
GOVERNMENT HAS FILLED THE VOID
TO MAINTAIN PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS I THINK IT'S AN
INTERESTING INVERSE
RELATIONSHIP THAT YOU ALL OUGHT
YOU CONSIDER. IMMEDIATELY
DECIDING WE'RE GOING TO START
DECREASING LICENSE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PATHWAYS TO ENTERING THIS
INDUSTRY YOU HAD A BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS. WELL THERE'S
A PRINT SHIPS AFTER THIRTY NINE
HOURS OF THEORETICAL
INSTRUCTION. YOU CAN
IMMEDIATELY GO TO WORK EARNING
WHILE YOU'RE LEARNING AS AN
APPRENTICE IN THIS INDUSTRY
THIRTY NINE HOURS HIS WORK.
THERE CAPPED AT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TOTAL AN
APPRENTICE CANNOT BE CHARGED
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS BY THEIR PROGRAM
SPONSOR OR ANYBODY. SO THERE IS
ONE AVENUE FOR LICENSE.
MOREOVER MY ASSOCIATION CREATED
AN EXTERNSHIP PROGRAM AFTER 60%
OF YOUR THEORETICAL INSTRUCTION
YOU ARE NOW ENTITLED BY LAW TO
GO TO A SALON TO BECOME AN X.
TURN FOR AN INTERN BUT WE
CALLED EXTERNAL. YOU CAN'T BE
PAID THAT'S A PROBLEM WE THINK
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE PAID
SO YOU AGAIN YOU CAN EARN WHILE
YOU LEARN THE APPRENTICE ONLY
HAD THIRTY NINE HOURS. AND CAN
BE PAID. IF SOMEONE TED NINE
HUNDRED HOURS OF INSTRUCTION
WHY CAN'T THEY ALSO BE PAID.
THEY CAN ALSO RECEIVE CLOCK OUR
CREDIT FOR THE TIME THAT THE
SERVICE AN EXTRA. SO THERE ARE
OTHER MEANS OF REDUCING THAT
BARRIER TO ENTRY. AND BY THE
WAY WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW
STATES OF THE FIFTY STATES BUT
DON'T JUST HAVE RECIPROCITY WE
HAVE WHAT'S CALLED LICENSE YOUR
BY ENDORSEMENT WHICH MEANS IF
YOU'VE BEEN LICENSE FOR THREE
OF THE LAST FIVE YEARS IN NEW
YORK AND YOU WANT TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA NO QUESTIONS ASKED
ESSENTIALLY AS LONG AS YOU
HAVEN'T SHOT SOMEBODY DURING
YOUR TIME IN THE SALON. YOU PAY
FIFTY DOLLARS AND YOU CAN BE
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
THE MOST GENEROUS WELCOMING
RECIPROCITY BECAUSE WE DON'T
CARE WHETHER NEW YORK ACCEPTS
OUR LICENSE OR NOT WE'RE
WILLING TO ACCEPT THEM INTO OUR
STATE. THE STATE BOARD MEMBERS
MENTION THIS ARTIST HIGHLIGHTED.
REGARDING CLOCK OUR CREDIT. THE
SINGLE LARGEST NUMBER OF
CONSUMER HARM COMPLAINTS
HAPPENS IN THE ONE SECTOR OF
OUR INDUSTRY THAT HAS THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF FORMAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. FOUR HUNDRED
HOURS FOR MAN A CARING AND
SEVEN OF THE TEN TOP CITED
VIOLATIONS. ARE IN MANY CURRENT
SALONS. SO I THINK THERE IS A
CORRELATION BETWEEN THOSE TWO
FACTORS. AND BY THE WAY ON ON
SCHOOLING MY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS AND ALTERNATIVE TO
CLOCK OUR CREDIT. THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS CLOCK OUR CREDIT
UNIVERSITIES. OR IT SEE ISSUES
OR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE ARE
WILLING TO EMBRACE COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO CLOCK HOUR. NOT
NECESSARILY TO REPLACE BECAUSE
AGAIN THAT WOULD COST SUCH UP
PEOPLE ARE SCHOOL SECTOR BUT
GIVE PROGRESSIVE SCHOOLS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE TOWARD
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION THE
STATE BOARD LAYS OUT ALL OF THE
MINIMUM. COMPETENCY STATE YOU
HAVE TO DO TO BE A LICENSEE.
THE STATE EXAM LICENSE EXAM
TEST THOSE COMPETENCIES. ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO VERIFY THE
PARTICULAR STUDENTS ARE
COMPETENT IN THOSE PROTOCOLS
AND MOVE THEM ALONG FASTER SO
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE THERE FOR
TEN MONTHS. NOW I CAUTION SOME
MAY BE THERE LONGER THAN TEN
MONTHS IF THEY'RE LESS
COMPETENT. THERE ARE A LOT OF
MY SCHOOLS IT SAY LET'S MOVE AT
LEAST HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE TO
**** OUR CREDIT AND MOVE TOWARD
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION.
FINALLY LET ME JUST SAY A WORD
ABOUT THE LICENSING EXAM. YOU
RECALL I STARTED THIS NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS AGO TOOK EIGHT
MONTHS FOR STUDENTS TO BE
EXAMINED. THE ELECTROLYTIC SAM
HAD NOT BEEN UPDATED FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO WE SUPPORTED AN EFFORT TO
HAVE THE STATE BOARD ADOPT THE
NATIONAL EXAM WHICH UPDATE EACH
OF OUR LICENSE CATEGORIES EVERY
THREE TO FIVE YEARS WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS FROM THE
INDUSTRY ST THIS IS OUR
OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS THIS IS
WHAT WE DO TO MAKE A LIVING IN
TODAY'S SALONS. THEREFORE THIS
IS WHAT SHOULD BE TESTED. THE
EXAM IS TWO PARTS. ONE EXAM
WITH TWO PARTS. THE THEORETICAL
IN THE HANDS ON I CANNOT STRESS
TO THIS TO YOU ALL HOW
IMPORTANT HANDS ON INSTRUCTION
IS IN THIS INDUSTRY THESE ARE
LEFT BRAIN ARTISTS. ALL THE
THEORY IN THE WORLD IS NOT
GOING TO PROTECT CONSUMERS IF
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO APPLY IT.
IT WAS MENTIONED THAT THE TWO
TO FOUR HUNDRED HOURS OF FORMAL
THEORY INSTRUCTION ON HEALTH
AND SAFETY SANITATION PROTOCOLS.
EVERY SERVICE DONE AT A SCHOOL.
HAS HEALTH AND SAFETY AS ITS
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE. SCHOOLS
ARE INTERESTED IN HOW GOOD THEY
CUT HAIR SCHOOLS ARE INTERESTED
IN HOUSE SAFELY THEY CUT HAIR
SO WHILE THE ONLY RECEIVED TWO
TO FOUR HUNDRED THEORETICALTHAT ENTIRE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS IS FOCUSED ON HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU MISTER JOHNSON YOUR HISTORY
AND YOUR EXPERIENCES A VERY
ENLIGHTENINGSECOND CAREER SO I'M KIND OF
THE JUNIOR AMONGST ALL THE
ADVOCATES AND BOARD MEMBERS ARE
HERE I'VE ONLY BEEN LICENSE
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. THE
MINUTE THAT I GOT SINCE I
FIGURED I'D- EVERYTHING ABOUT
HOW THIS. AT THE HEAD I'M
RUNNING BE COMPETITIVE WITH ALL
THOSE TWENTY YEAR OLDS OUT
THERE. SO. FACEBOOK GROUP AND
WE ARE CALIFORNIA ESTHETICIAN
ESTHETICIAN ADVOCACY WE ARE
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS
RIGHT NOW AND THEN. ALLIANCE IN
WHICH WE HAVE ATTENDED AND
SPOKEN UP AGAINST MANY OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT IS KIND OF
COME OUT US THAT COULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. ARMS AS THE NAIL
TECHS. SENATE SENATE BILL
NUMBER TWO IN THE SIX SENATE
BILL NINE NINE NINE. AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN B. R. COMPENSATION. AB
I AB FIVE CURRENTLY THAT
AFFECTS. IN THE LAST ISSUE RENT
ROOMS. THE SOMEONE SUTTER IN
CALIFORNIA. OF FRED HIS TOUCH
MUCH OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALSO
EMBRACE AS PART OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND- OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP. DEAD THE
AESTHETICIAN MORE NERDY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE ALWAYS IN THE
BOOKS WE ARE THE ONES THAT
ALWAYS INTO THE CONTINUING
CATION AND ARE KEEPING YOU IN
EDUCATION COM A LOT MORE IN
JERRY BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A
QUICK ADVANCEMENT. OF IN TWO.
FEDEX WORLD SERVICES AND IN
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAPPEN HAVE
MEDICAL OVERSIGHT OF LICENSEES
WE ALSO DON'T IT HASN'T AS AN
ENTIRE BOARD HAVE CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROP. SEC WHEN MR
GLAZER MENTIONED ABOUT THE PLEA
BEING HALF THE TIME THAT WE
HAVE FOR A COSMETOLOGIST.
INTERESTING BECAUSE ONCE WE GET.
HUNDRED HOURS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS THAT'S THE REST OF OUR
CAREER WE HAVE NO REQUIREMENT
FOR CONTINUING EDUCATION. WE
ALSO HAVE NO PLACE FOR.
DEMONSTRATING COMPETENCY AND
SHOWING THAT ADVANCED
CERTIFICATION OF ALL THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT COME OUT AND
HIT OUR INDUSTRY PRETTY QUICKLY
ESPECIALLY IN THE STATUS
CATEGORY THERE'S NO PLACE FOR A.
YES I CERTIFICATION. SO WHEN WE
ARE ALLOWED TO APPLY EYELASHES
TO A PERSON THAT BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN YOU
ESTABLISH THE LICENSE YES THIS
XIN WHICH IS THE LAST TIME
WE'VE HAD OUR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
OF REVISED THAT MEAN JUST HI
FALSE EYELASHES TO A PERSON
TODAY THAT MEANS SLASH PENSIONS.
YES I'M TAKING TO THERE'S A-
APB D. PLASTICS LASH WITH A
COSMETICS TO MEDICAL GRADE
SUPERGLUE TO IN A TO A CLIENT'S
EYES. SO THOSE CERTIFICATIONS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
HAVE KNOWLEDGE AND HAVE ON
BOARD AS PART OF OUR
REQUIREMENTS IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE WE DO MOVE REALLY
QUICKLY. AND I FROM THAT ALSO
SINCE WE HAVEN'T HAD A SCOPE OF
PRACTICE REVISION SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT ANOTHER
SERVICE THAT GOES HAND IN HAND
WITH THAT IS SOMETHING LIKE AN
AYE LAST TERM. PROBABLY NONE OF
YOU HAD AN EYELASH FOR MAYBE
TWO IF YOU I DON'T KNOW. THIS
IS SOMETHING IN AN ESTHETICIAN
CANNOT DO BECAUSE PERM
EYELASHES. BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE PERMANENT OUR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE HENCE WHY WE ARE SO
APPRECIATED OF YOU LISTENING TO
US IN OUR NEED TO HAVE A SCOPE
OF PRACTICE REVISION BECAUSE
OUR EGGMAN. THE IN THE HOUSE SO
QUICKLY. EVERY WEEK TO SEND AN
EMAIL TO CHRISTY AND WOULD WITH
SOME SORT OF CRAZY THING THAT
IS COME FROM OVERSEAS THAT WE
ARE NOW TRYING TO DO TO OUR
FACES. AND IT'S CRAP SO WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO UPDATE OUR
LANGUAGE AND TO CONSIDER THAT
DODD TECHNOLOGY OF FORMULATIONS
AND MACHINERY THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO US AND THAT SORT
OF THING NEED TO MOVE ALONG THE
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE THAT WE
NEED A CORRECTED BECAUSE WE
LEFT WAY BEHIND WHAT WE WERE
ALLOWED TO DO IN NINETEEN.
SEVENTY EIGHT. DIFFERENT HI.
SPECS OF OUR LIFE. SO I AM SO
EXCITED TO HAVE THIS BURKE
THANK YOU MISTER MISS COCHRAN
FOR COMING IN AND SHARING YOUR
THOUGHTS AND WE WOULD WELCOME
ANY CORRESPONDENCE WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF IN TERMS. OF
PRACTICE REVISIONS THAT YOU
THINK ARE APPROPRIATE. SO I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL WELCOME
THAT I SEE SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EXPERTISE
TESTIMONY MY GOODNESS YOUR-
OFFERINGS BUT WE'VE WAITED
ABOUT DOING. THAT WOMAN TAPPED
TO THERE IT BRAWLS NOW AND
EYELASHES ARE PERMANENT AND
TOOK IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE.
YOUR INDUSTRIES PART OF IS THAT
SOMETHING SEPARATE OUT HOW DO
YOU. TAKE CARE OF THAT WELL
MISTER I SHOULD LET I HAVEN'T
SEEN YOU SINCE THE CHEERLEADER
PICKUP LINE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX TESTING GIVE A HIGH SCHOOL
SO LOADED ON FOR ME. SET WE
MANY OF YOUR I'M. AND SO BUT I
HAVE EXPERIENCE FROM THIS GROUP
OF VERY VOCAL MEMBERSHIP OF
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE IT IS KIND
OF A CROSS OVER OTHER STATES
HAVE THE PERMANENT MAKE UP AS
PART OF THEIR RECALL SMALL
OVERSIGHT. BUT WE DO NOT IT'S
ALL THE MANAGED BY THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND AT THE
REGULATIONS CHANGE BY THE K. G.
SO WHETHER YOU CAN DO BEAUTY
SERVICES AND PERMANENT MAKEUP
SERVICES IN THE SAME ROOM. AS
DIFFERENT IN ALL THE COUNTIES
WHETHER WE CAN DO TO. SERVICES
ON TUESDAY A IN THAT ROOM AND
THEN HAVE TO SWITCH THE WHOLE
THING OVER FOR THE TORY
REQUIREMENTS OF. THE THEIR
AGENCY ON THURSDAY FRIDAY SAT.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE-
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
THAT ARE NOT PART OF OURS
PRACTICE SO THE PERMANENT
MAKEUP BUT ALSO THINGS LIKE
FIBROBLAST OR PLOT PLASMANET
WERE PLAN PLAN MERE PANS WHICH
YOUR LITTLE WELL VICE THAT
CREATES OFF SURGERY AND GIVE
YOU A LITTLE LIFT IN YOUR FACE
AFTER YOU'VE LITERALLY WELDED
WITH A MICROCHIP ON YOUR SKIN.
HANNAH IS SO THE SPEECH MUSIC
PLACES. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO GO THERE AND INVEST
BRINGING THESE THINGS AND BUT A
LOT OF OUR ON REGULATED THINGS
THAT A LOT OF INSTITUTIONS IN
BE SERVICES END UP KIND OF
BEING STASHED IN THOSE
CATEGORIES. BECAUSE IT'S A BIT
DIFFERENT THAT HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL. DAYS THERE
THERE THERE IT. EVERY YEAR OR
EVERY OTHER YEAR DEPENDING ON
THE COUNTY WITH IT'S ALL RANDOM.
SO WHEN THAT CROSSOVER HAPPENS
IT'S OUR LICENSE FOR BEAUTY HAS
TO GO UP ALL OF OUR STANDARDS
FOR THE REGULATIONS HAVE TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED AND THEN WHEN WE
WHEN WE HAVE A PM YOU CLIENT
COME IN WE HAVE TO TAKE ALL
THAT DOWN WE NEED TO CHANGE
OVER THE ROOM TO BEAT THEIR
REGULATIONS AND A LOT OF TIMES
THAT DAY. AND HOW IT JUST KIND
OF AND- THINGS THAT ARE SEEN AS
MORE MEDICAL THAT ARE BEING
HIDDEN IN THESE FOR. WE DON'T
SEE AS MUCH IN THE
BEAUTIFICATION SIR GIVING
FACIALS DOING LASH EXTENSIONS
AND THAT SORT OF THING. VERY
GOOD Q. I CHIRLA. OF THOSE
PRACTITIONERS IN IN THE FIELDS
TO BEST UNDERSTAND WHAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO AND ADVANCING
THE TECHNOLOGY SO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AS WE ARE NOW
GLOBAL ECONOMY FOR. THE
ORGANIST CAN YOU SEVEN
CALIFORNIA S. IS. IS THAT
CORRECT WE HAVE A FACEBOOK
GROUP OF ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE OKAY IS FOR LICENSEES
ONLY AND THEY'RE ALMOST ALL THE
LOS OKAY WE ARE ALL THE GALLON.
BRENT. BACK ROOM FOR RENT THE
ROOM DOWN THE HALL. MED SPA
THINGS. IN THIS GROUP ARE YOU
COOPERATED WITH THE SECTOR
STAGE OF BY LAW. CALIFORNIA'S
ATTIC ALLIANCE IS ON ITS WAY TO
BEING INCORPORATED BUT WE HAVE
THIS MY ATTORNEYS KIND AND NOT
SURE IF FOR POLITICAL. FIVE A
ONE OKAY DO YOU BUY LAWS WE
WILL BE HAVING BY LICENCES
CURRENTLY DO NOT BY LOSS IN THE
FACEBOOK GROUP NOW OKAY THERE
ARE LAWS TO THE GROUP GOT IT TO
THE ORGANIZATION IS NOT
STRUCTURE THERE'S NOT RECORD
DISSECT A STATE OR NO BY LAWS.
CORRECT THERE ARE NO PAID
MEMBERSHIP DUES. OKAY SO. TO
TURN YOU ADVOCATE. FIVE THE
NUMBER IS FACEBOOK GROUP. OKAY
BUT HOW DO YOU HOW DO WE THE
BEST UNDERSTAND HOW TO BEST
COMMUNICATE WITH THAT OF THE
REPRESENTATION OF THE
PRACTITIONERS IN THE FIELD HOW
IS THE KIND OF STRUCTURED IN
PLACE TO DO WE COMMUNITY INVEST
WITH LOOSELY FOR THE GROUP OF
FIVE AND THESE ARE SELECTED
INDIVIDUALS HERE NO OPPORTUNITY
TO AND A FIVE THEY WERE NOT
THERE ACCESS LICENSEES IS THAT
CORRECT. I'M AYE AT EACH ONE OF
THE MEMBERS STATES THEIR LEGAL
NAME WHAT CITY THERE IN AND
THEIR LICENSE NUMBER. OR
THERE'S- AND I GET ALL FIVE
THOUSAND. OF INTEGRITY AND
UNDERSTANDING WHO WERE TALKING
TO AND IT IS THE TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE I'M SURE THERE'S A
DIVERSE OPINION OF MANY
PRACTITIONERS IN THE FIELD TO.
PRIORITIZE WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS
A STATE AND WHAT THEIR
REGULATORY FOR. THE SHOULD BE
WITHIN INDUSTRY AS WELL
ABSOLUTELY AND ACTUALLY YOUR
COMMUNITY WITH THEM RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN THE
QUESTIONS I ANYBODY ELSE HERE
TO TESTIFY ON THIS POP BRING ON
THE ON THE ISSUE AT HAND. I SEE
A NO ONE SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR COMING.
YOUR THOUGHTS AND FOR THOSE WHO
ARE LISTING OR HERE DISSIPATING
THANK YOU YOUR UP TO STATION
TAKE EACH YEAR LOW FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS. AND TAKING
PART WHY THE CARP THE PLAN IS
TO HAVE A SECOND HERE.
NOTIFICATION FOR THAT. IS IT
YOUR